okay everybody I have the honor today of
being joined by Madeline Knight who
plays Greta from love death in the
robots episode seven beyond the aquila
rift Madeline how are you doing today
I'm very well thank you Steve yeah this
is pretty crazy cuz I'm in New York
right now and I'm talking to you all the
way in London so it's awesome that you
did this for me
so think I really want to know about
this is how did a part like this come
about for you did you have to audition
for the role I did yeah I did that was
quite a while ago now because we filmed
everything in November 2017 so I think
my audition was October that year or
something like that was like a voice
audition or did you have to actually be
in person and act out in front of them
no it was it was a perfect person
audition I went in to see Christina
Eddie who was passing out gymnast
nothing ad and I had two auditions so
but because it's such a big project we
weren't able to know anything about the
project whatsoever so we basically got
given two scenes and a very quick
character breakdown it was like sort of
an idea of what the character was and
the rest you just have to go for it so I
mean in some ways it was good because
you don't get too stressed out about the
nature of like the massiveness of the
project so you don't get too nervous to
pressures too excited and to get too
disappointed if you don't get the role
so that's good but it's very we did have
very little to go on
Wow okay okay so then in that case when
you did get the role and got the news
did they tell you then that like okay
this is a David Fincher tim miller
project it's gonna be on netflix or how
did that go about well i didn't actually
find out to the first day of filming cuz
we all haven't find our NDA's until then
on disclosure so i just come off the
back of another job which was pulled up
cause i think you have in the states as
well yeah during Aidan Turner gave on it
so that's like a proper big period drama
but just literally finished that job and
I arrived at Paddington Station with a
suitcase
going like I'm ready to work so I met
the directors Maxine and Dominic you
don't bear
and then we had this train ride up to
Oxford where the audio motion studios
were that we were filming in where none
of us were allowed to connect and as
soon as we got there and signed the
contract the NDA's all of the news came
out and obviously everyone was super
excited and obviously these guys are
absolutely epic and I spent my childhood
watching all their projects so yeah it
was surreal
so also at this point when did they let
you know to like oh we're also going to
use your actual face for the animation
like that's crazy enough I yeah I they
were using actual things because
obviously that's right use and the way
my face emotes and all that sort of
stuff we were filming with huge heads
headset and I'll tell you a little bit
more about that later but what I didn't
know was the likeness that there was
going to be because at that point they
weren't clear on how stylized the
avatars going to be because like the
design the design with in its early
stages and so I mean it could have been
anything like I just didn't look
extremely different from what I actually
looked like but seeing it absolutely
shocked and amazed like how like my
house with his patina was amazing and a
testament to the talent of those people
at unit image you were working on it
not in months yeah I mean when I watched
this episode I I had never seen you
before so I didn't know - I was like are
these created faces by just characters
they made are these real actors and
actresses and I looked up your name and
I was like oh my god like this is
amazing like it really looked human it
didn't even look animated like it really
was yeah and so when you're explaining
this headphone thing you were wearing
was there like something like scanning
your face at the same time was there any
body acting involved to this or was it
just voice right then it's not just
voice work it's very very different so
it's a mocap process so basically in
that process the actors are dressed head
to toe in black suits which are then
then we have reflective balls that are
velcroed onto these
but in sort of your piece clinical areas
and your joints so then you go onto the
set which is basically like a large
hangar with huge steel frames around you
that all hang off infrared cameras and
they pick up on these reflective balls
so they can capture your motion as a
motion capture and so that was what was
doing like capturing our bodies and then
we have the headset serious cutting-edge
technology that was flown over from the
states and they're on our heads and we
had lights shining in our faces and they
were picking up all of the emissions
that were being shown whilst filming our
base and also filming our voice so all
of the voice work was actually done in
situ in in the rehearsal on set as it
were so the only bits that were done as
your quintessential voice work was when
we did the dubbing for some bit that
wasn't particularly clear so that point
we went over Paris and did the taping
for that but that was actually quite a
small percentage of the script that we
had to do that for so you would say then
it was more like recording any other TV
or film work you've done were you were
actually in the room with the other
characters and there's a director on set
but you guys are wearing these suits is
that what basically wow that is see I
wouldn't even know that watching it at
you know Wow it was so amazing too
because I I put a background in theater
as well as screen and it was for me it
was a real mix between doing theater and
film acting so because you're in this
space with very like little props like
for the surge tank and stuff there's a
wooden block with some feel against that
you can lean on and work sort of stuff
your props with very rudimentary as well
as reflective both of them so it felt
like being in a theater rehearsal space
you know it was all being filmed acting
is a lot smaller and it's you know
acting in so much very different
obviously the intention is the same but
it is slightly different so the real mix
between the two and I actually really
enjoyed it because if you're on set with
all of the film set there
and then it's your shot and it's very
much like the pressure is on whereas all
of the shots were being taken but it
didn't it still felt like we were in
rehearsal probably what extremely well
sure yeah probably loosened us up more
right yeah well I feel like you had a
very complicated character to play and
obviously with their value being an
alien but you're also playing in the
simulation it's controlling of Greta for
a role like this when you saw it was
there any movies or shows or characters
you'd watched in previous media that
maybe helped you prepare for this role
or did you kind of go in with your own
idea like how did that work I mean I
think like as I said we didn't really
have enough time we started filming two
seconds after finding out what the
project was and the script was still in
formation in the first week so they were
still massive and two edits happening so
really we only got like a real full
feeling at the tone of it by the end of
the first week I would say were filming
so that kind of preparation wasn't
wasn't an option really I'm not quite
sure if I what I would use to if I had
the chance again to watch but I would
probably go with just a simple romantic
drama or something like that
right right the me a lot of this is a
love story rather than looking at
something that's similarly stylized I
don't think that would be a help I don't
think that would have been of any help
because that was just sort of my your
own thoughts of the actual script and
what's on the page and it's very
important just to stay in what's on the
page
I think brilliant now knowing this that
you kind of jumped into it which is
really crazy enough did they let you
know though like hey you're the alien in
the end or do you kind of just know at
first you're playing this girl Greta
well the audition I only knew about the
Greta part definitely and obviously when
I saw the script on the first day then
yeah I knew that was gonna happen
which was interesting right so yeah so
when you saw that did you angle then
when you're playing this character of
Greta were you thinking in terms in your
head of the alien like being this alien
or you kind of it was it easier for you
maybe just to think of it being this
Greta who was in Toms life
the past I think I thought of it as an
entity in whatever shape or form but
that entity whoever it is if someone who
loves and wants to protect on and I
think Greta felt that way when they knew
each other as well that it was easy to
sort of conjoin the two and when I was
playing Greta it was never just Greta
it was Greta with a plan or Greta with a
secret but I always played her with the
best intentions for Tom so yeah okay a
mystical seductress somewhat like a
mermaid like faders and then disappears
yes
so for like a mystical character like
that that you see as an entity which is
really smart process did you
in addition create a backstory for maybe
the alien in your head or even just this
woman Greta but what she was like on
earth or you kind of just leave that be
know what I think well Henry do straight
okay Tom marvelously I might add we
definitely discussed the relationship
between Greta and Tom what that was
beforehand because obviously that's not
an escape but it's something that would
massively inform the connection that we
had together so we definitely discussed
their backstory but not so much
backstory I think I just thought about
what the aliens stood for in terms of
the story and the narrative but you know
I didn't think about if the alien had a
child so speaking of that running off
what you're saying do you think then
this alien had good intentions here or
bad intentions because some fans are
skeptical that this alien really the
whole time was just planning to
eventually eat Tom and eat Susie and
just eat whoever came to this planet but
I was someone who thought no it's just
caring for these people and helping them
like accept the reality what was your
kind of belief on that I mean I really
like that people had that interpretation
because I think that's what great that
was great about this piece is that
different people could come away with
different stories things that relate to
themselves that other people wouldn't
you know taking from the store and I
think that's what makes a really good
piece of
but no I wasn't in the camp that thought
the alien was eating people I was and
definitely thinking Balian was a
benevolent creature and I took the word
you know before the reveal the words
that Greta says to Tom and I care for
all of you lost souls etcetera I took
those troops and I paid the first Ruth
and I thought that was the words from
the creature that is seed that is what I
thought god that's amazing to hear for
the last scene as well I thought it was
really important but it was injected
with some element of sadness because for
me the character aggressor or the
creature itself has just had this
harrowing experience with Tom I mean he
wakes up and sees his actual reality and
she has to start the process all over
again remembering that experience where
Tom completely oblivious we can just
turn off to it the sheath has been
through that experience and she's out
there she's having to go through this on
a roll over and over again and that's
quite an interesting thought as well as
actually living in the hell because
Tom's being fed the simulations but this
creature seems to spend her entire life
repeatedly experiencing but torment at
the people that she's trying to detect I
think I'd rather become in that
situation yeah I see that angle now
that's actually mind-blowing that you
say that so do you think then like yeah
in a sense we all can just jump and look
at tom is the victim here but yeah you
can look at it also as this alien
suffering - and do you think then you
thinking that this aliens good
intentions and that's how you played it
that the alien actually loved Tom or was
just comforting more in like a friendly
way what how did you see that or play
that I would call it love in a sort of
wider sense in a sort of is like God
like loves of a larger entity with a
lesser being if that makes sense right
me totally I think I think the creature
certainly loves Tom and all the bees are
the lost souls certainly doesn't love
Tom in the same way [ __ ] loves company
right okay so do you think also at all
you know that last night she's
referencing all these lost souls that
she's been through this before do you
think these are all just like
failed attempts at doing this and that
she just keeps trying or they just
eventually die like how did you look at
that when she was saying that line I
personally think that this planet is
littered with these crashed travelers
and either just the character of Greta
the creature that becomes Greta is
looking after all of these lost souls or
she's got a whole load of other alien
colleagues that are doing the same thing
but obviously this is my interpretation
and as I said everyone's got their own
interpretation so there's no right and
there's no wrong in this but I thought
when I saw it when when Tom wakes up
that they are slowly withering away and
I think that what Greta this creature
Greta the creature is doing is just
making his final moments in in her on
her planet more palatable as he
Twitter's away do you through a means
they'll eventually he'll eventually go
but he'll be in this gene like state
that makes it easier for that to happen
and I like the idea of lost souls as
well because it really implies that
there's somewhere so completely
different where they came from that not
even their souls have the chance of
returning to the plane on which they can
possibly exist that make sense yeah we
think of souls being the only thing that
can exist past our physical being but
the idea of being such isolation that
even the soul can exist that really
takes it to another like hell like it's
a night place which is really quite
disturbing no yeah that that really no
that's that's deep that's heavy I like
that and yeah I felt like it visually
looks like that too at the end and I
really added to the shock of the whole
episode to be honest so at the end I was
referred and what did you feel though
like when you know the audience takes us
all in has a big twist people loved what
did you feel like this episode's message
was like what was it trying to tell like
what do you think I I don't think there
is one message and I don't I don't I
wouldn't I wouldn't say it was message
it's more that there are questions that
it lays out and themes that it touches
on but again these will be different for
everybody but
it certainly for me provokes a huge
number of metaphysical questions such as
like reality existence being you know
really question your own reality after
this and how do we know it's real and
how many possible other planes are there
for us to exist on and I think there's
also questions about the importance of
close relationships to our existence in
the home and are these are these
connections what makes life worth living
in in total she said I mean yeah like
right now I'm actually questioning if
I'm really interviewing you
or is this madeline yeah alien you could
be an alien I'm talking to right now no
I totally mean crisis about like the
cyclical repetitive nature of life and
dying in isolation which is quite joyful
I do you think it it does aim to disturb
a lot so last question I have for you to
just curiosity at any point during
filming or even after did you read the
book it was based on beyond the keel or
if the same title I did after this and
it
I really recommend anyone reading it
certainly the lost souls scene is really
beautifully written and actually the
whole short story collection by Alastair
Reynolds is worth a read because then
you lose another one of the films is
also from that collection oh wow yeah
that's that
yeah got it um and also is gonna say I
feel like for you you know oh for people
in general that a big dream a lot of
people have was one day to be now in a
Netflix show or one day to have a video
game character created out of them and I
feel like you hit two birds with one
stone here and I feel like you know that
that must have been so cool to like to
your family and friends to be like
that's me like that's an animated
version of me and possibly the best
technology out there to see it you know
like no like was that a crazy experience
just like watching it or seeing it with
friends or how did that feel
unbelievable yeah I mean my friends have
absolutely loved it and my family I
don't think my dad was completely
comfortable watching it before he did
with watch a little bit and then close
his eyes now I did see and a lot of
episodes of love death and robots people
are calling for like hey let's make like
it's a own series for it like it's its
own standalone series could you see
beyond the aquila rift something that
would be like hey we could do a couple
episodes of this would you be interested
in that like is that something oh my god
I know that people you know image had
way more stuff that they wanted to put
in because you know the story is really
fit for a future feature-length and so
there would be no problem in doing that
and certainly the enthusiasm on all
sides would probably be through the roof
that would say yeah let's cross our
fingers yeah what is uh is there any
social media you guys want us to follow
like Twitter or Instagram can we find
you on that yeah you can find me on that
awesome
Madeleine thank you so much for coming
on I'm truly grateful for it you were
fantastic in the role it was such a
pleasure yeah it was so great thank you
have a great day and I hope to see you
and more stuff soon thank you very much
bye now